catching wild Burmese pythons takes
serious skills only 100 people are
licensed to capture these snakes in
Florida where the invasive pest has
decimated local wildlife and biologists
like Michaela Spencer say euthanizing
the snakes is the only way to control
the problem we've always had people
asking if you have you thought about
rehoming them could we send them back to
their native country well you know
remember these animals are established
in a whole different ecosystem they
could have different diseases and things
like that so we really can't ship them
anywhere else she works for the FWC and
showed us how Hunters can capture the
snakes safely the second I had her pin
right behind that head I reached in and
grabbed if she goes around my leg it can
be a good example of like why I give her
a leg and not my arms she's actually
staying relatively calm after capturing
probably because that back and forth
tired her out but I've got my leg here
I'm not sitting on her just to be clear
I don't put any weight on a snake
sometimes they'll just put themselves in
the bag once you start to feed them in
there they double bag it and put it
inside a lock box